so notice that when the X term was
positive our hyperbola opened to the
right and the left Sal Khan is the CEO
of non profit on-demand educational
resource Khan Academy he started making
educational videos and compatible
practice software in 2004 for his
cousin's that offer lessons and many
levels of mathematics and science and
they became viral with many more people
turning to him and asking him to create
even more lessons in a variety of areas
now he's doing it full-time and Khan
Academy is a designated Forbes name you
need to know in 2011 a recent blog post
on Khan's new approach to education
which takes the lectures out of the
classroom leaving more room for
project-based learning at school sparked
quite the conversation online Bruce up
and brings up the point that there's not
a chance on Khan Academy to ask
follow-up questions I think at least the
way I think about it is let's say you
have a question and you're doing
calculus you have a question on limits
there's a video on limits and you can go
back and you can click that 10 minute
video on limits and just the act of that
is like you know what I don't understand
limits can you explain a little bit more
on that and if you're still stuck if you
don't even know how to navigate or know
what you should be looking at to answer
your question we have a pretty vibrant
community we have a million users a
month so to Bruce the second point about
hands-on learning it's a completely fair
point and why I think what Khan Academy
enables is more time in the classroom
for actual hands-on learning the
students are getting the lecture at home
at their own pace they can remediate if
they need to and now they can go to the
classroom and do project-based learning
and spend more time with a professor the
kerkoff's point about taking a
relationship for connection with the
teacher to really get deep understanding
I think that's true I think would be a
very optimistic if we think a lot of
students are getting that deep intimate
connection in the classroom right now I
think most students aren't and to some
degree and even though it is virtual it
is strange but I get a lot of feedback
from a lot of users that they feel a
deep intimate connection with me that I
feel like their neighbor or their older
and that I'm sitting next to them and
all the at the kitchen table and
teaching the math I love Christopher
Hellmann's point and you know I'm glad I
was able to help his wife to his point
about replacing universities I don't
think it's going to happen anytime soon
but I think it's an interesting idea and
I think to think about that we have to
realize that a university is two things
it's a credential and it's learning
I think Khan Academy is going to be able
to really change how the learning part
is done in a pretty significant way the
credentialing part you know getting your
degree from Stanford or Harvard that'll
probably be there for a little while I
think if you fast-forward a 10 years
from now I mean it's not going to happen
overnight I mean this is social change
happening 10 years 20 years I think an
employer would rather see your log from
a site like Khan Academy where it
doesn't just get a 3.2 GPA in psychology
it gets what you did when you did it how
well you did it how well were you able
to help your peers how how consistently
did you work wow this guy worked three
hours every day for 20 years on this
stuff this is this is a persistent kind
of guy that I want to I want working for
me and will be able to give people that
type of analytics I think that could be
a more powerful transcript than just a
high level degree right now